honduras is about to swear in the
country's first woman president
siomara castro's historic victory in the
november elections ended a highly
polarized election season marred by
violence and fears of social unrest
we are going to form a government of
reconciliation in our country a
government of peace and a government of
justice
castro's presidency marks an end to the
12-year rule by the conservative
national party led by controversial
president juan orlando hernandez
but a power struggle in the honduran
national congress threatens to derail
the new president's political agenda and
analysts say the discord could plunge
the country into a full-blown crisis
we have to find a balance in order to
avoid this fire from spreading
right now it's manageable but if we
don't seek out a solution and instead
add fuel to this fire
we're all going to get burned
siomara castro is the wife of former
honduran president manuel celaya who was
ousted during a coup in 2009
as a presidential candidate castro
promised to restore democratic
institutions and root out corrupt
government officials
even before the start of the latest
political crisis in honduras addressing
the many problems facing the country
like violence poverty systemic
corruption and an economic crisis
exacerbated by the pandemic was a tall
order for the new president
now with a growing rift in the honduran
legislature the international community
is calling for a dialogue but average
citizens say what they want is for the
government to simply do its job
as a young person i am longing for there
to be jobs for all young people all
adults and the elderly
that there are laws in favor of women
and for men too for children for animals
the incoming administration of ciumara
castro is seen by many as an opportunity
to turn the page on more than a decade
of scandal and political turmoil but if
the current conflict is not resolved
it's an opportunity that could be
squandered before castro's presidency
even begins
manuel rapalo al jazeera tegucigalpa